Herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem Kanal.
Willkommen zu einem neuen Video.
Heute zeige ich euch, wie ihr ganz kräftige,
gesunde, vitale Tomatenpflänzchen selber
vorziehen könnt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt: Tomatenpflanzen
werden, wenn sie unter schlechten Bedingungen
vorgezogen werden, ganz schnell dünn, langgezogen,
gelb und schwächlich.
Und um das zu verhindern, gilt es einige Sachen
zu beachten.
Und wie das genau funktioniert mit der Tomatenanzucht,
das zeige ich euch Schritt für Schritt in
diesem Video, so dass ihr richtig kräftige
und vitale Tomaten in eurem Garten pflanzen
könnt.
Ja, wann sollte man denn mit der Tomatenanzucht
anfangen?
Das kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an, wo
man die Tomaten später pflanzen möchte.
Tomaten, die ins Gewächshaus kommen, können
schon ein bisschen früher vorgezogen werden
als die Tomaten, die dann ins Freiland gepflanzt
werden.
Im Freiland kann man erst ab Mitte Mai pflanzen,
weil dann die Eisheiligen vorbei sind, weil
dann keine Fröste mehr drohen.
Im Gewächshaus kann man das teilweise schon
ein paar Wochen früher machen, deswegen fange
ich mit der Voranzucht für die Gewächshaustomaten
Ende Februar an, und mit der Voranzucht für
die Freilandtomaten erst Mitte März.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Ich sehe das immer wieder, dass ganz viele
Leute schon im Januar anfangen, ihre Tomaten
zu säen.
Gerade auf Facebook, da sieht man dann immer
die ganzen Posts, und da denke ich immer nur
so „Ah!
Wartet doch noch ein bisschen!“
Ich kann das so gut nachvollziehen, dass man
so viel Gartenvorfreude in sich hat, dass
man unbedingt mit den ersten Aussaaten anfangen
möchte.
Aber diese Tomaten, die müssen dann so lange
drinnen ausharren, bis sie endlich nach draußen
gepflanzt werden können, dass es sinnvoller
ist, ein bisschen zu warten, und die Tomaten
wirklich erst dann vorzuziehen, wenn es auch
soweit ist, sprich Ende Februar oder Mitte
März, je nachdem, ob sie ins Gewächshaus
oder ins Freiland kommen, weil den Tomatenpflanzen,
denen wird es auf Dauer viel zu eng in den
Töpfchen, wenn die so lange im Haus warten
müssen, bis sie dann endlich in die Beete
wandern können.
Deswegen: Haltet euch besser an die vorgesehenen
Aussaatzeitpunkte, das ist immer sinnvoller.
Ich säe mein Gemüse nach dem Maria Thun
Kalender aus, dem Demeter-Kalender.
Den kann ich euch gerne noch einmal hier unter
dem Video verlinken.
Deswegen achte ich bei der Aussaat auch immer
darauf, dass ich die Tomaten möglichst an
einem Fruchttag aussäe, damit sie später
auch viele Früchte tragen.
Welche Anzuchterde sollte man denn jetzt für
Tomaten verwenden?
Ich verwende entweder gekaufte Anzuchterde,
da achte ich immer darauf, dass die bio und
torffrei ist.
Aber viel, viel lieber, gerade für Starkzehrer,
die Tomaten ja sind, verwende ich schlichtweg
gut gereiften, gesiebten Kompost.
Und da denken einige jetzt wahrscheinlich
„Ah!
In Kompost kann man doch nichts aussäen!“
Aber doch, das kann man.
Ich mache das seit Jahren so, und ich habe
viel bessere Erfahrungen gemacht, die Tomaten
direkt in Kompost auszusäen, als wenn ich
Anzuchterde nehme, die ja sehr nährstoffarm
ist.
Deswegen: So lange ich genug Kompost habe,
ist das immer mein erste Wahl.
Immer.
Bevor die Tomatensamen in die Erde kommen,
habe ich aber noch einen kleinen Geheimtipp
für euch: Und zwar keime ich Tomaten immer
vor in so kleinen Zipptütchen, die sammle
ich immer, und dann nehme ich Küchenpapier,
feuchte das an, verteile darauf die Samen
einer Sorte, klappe das zusammen, und packe
das hier in dieses Zipptütchen, weil so können
die Samen vorkeimen.
Das hat die Vorteile, dass die Keimrate sehr
viel besser ist, das heißt, von den Samen,
die man sät, gehen sehr viel mehr Samen auf,
und das geht sehr viel schneller.
Und deswegen beschrifte ich die dann immer
– das ist hier die Sorte Celsior – und
säe dann immer meine Samen in diesen Tütchen
aus und lasse die so vorkeimen.
Weil Tomaten ja so wärmebedürftig sind,
ist es wichtig, dass die Keimtemperatur zwanzig
bis 24 Grad beträgt.
Die wollen es also schön gemütlich warm
haben beim Keimen, deswegen lege ich die immer
unter die Heizung, und da können die dann
ein paar Tage vorkeimen.
Da muss man regelmäßig nachschauen, ob sich
die Samen schon entwickelt haben.
Wenn da so kleine Spitzen aus den Samen rausschauen,
dann ist es Zeit, dass die in die Erde umziehen.
Wenn du Lust hast, das Projekt Gemüsegarten
in diesem Jahr einmal so richtig anzugehen,
richtig durchzustarten in deinem Garten, dann
komm gerne in mein Gemüsegarten-Boot-Camp.
Das ist mein kostenloser Video Minikurs, bei
dem ich dir zeige vom Beete anlegen über
das Aussäen bis hin zu meinen besten Zeitspartipps
im Hochsommer, was du alles beachten musst,
um einen richtig erfolgreichen, ertragreichen,
pflegeleichten und produktiven Gemüsegarten
zu haben.
Da kannst du dich gern kostenlos für anmelden,
der Link ist unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall, wenn du da
mit dabei bist.
Da ist auch schon eine ganz tolle Gemeinschaft
entstanden aus ganz vielen Gartenfreunden,
die sich immer gegenseitig weiterhelfen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz tolle Sache.
Aber kommen wir zurück zu unseren Tomatensamen.
Sobald die gekeimt sind, und sich da die ersten
Keimspitzen zeigen, ist es Zeit, die auszusäen.
Und das mache ich am Anfang immer in einem
größeren Topf.
Ich nehme mir ungefähr so einen großen Topf,
fülle den mit reifem Kompost, wie eben schon
erklärt, und dann säe ich alle ein Zentimeter
einen Zentimeter tief ein Samenkorn und befeuchte
das gut und stelle das wieder unter die Heizung,
so dass weiterhin eine Temperatur von ungefähr
zwanzig bis 24 Grad herrscht, so dass die
Samen gut keimen können.
Und sobald die ersten Pflanzen aufgegangen
sind, sollten die dann an einen Ort umziehen,
an dem es ungefähr 16 bis 18 Grad hat.
Danach mögen die es nämlich eher ein bisschen
kühler.
Das ist wichtig, damit die Pflanzen schön
kräftig und gedrungen werden.
Es ist natürlich ganz wichtig, dass man die
Erde immer feucht hält, das versteht sich
wahrscheinlich von selber, also die Erde darf
nie austrocknen, weil sonst können da auch
keine Samen mehr aufgehen.
Eine Sache ist noch ganz wichtig beim Aussäen,
und das vergesse ich auch jedes Mal wieder:
Nämlich dass man die Sorten beschriftet.
Es ist so schade, wenn man Tomatenpflänzchen
vorzieht und am Ende nicht mehr weiß, was
das für eine Sorte war, so dass man am Ende
nicht mehr weiß „Boah, die hat mir besonders
gut geschmeckt.“ und „Die hat mir nicht
so gut geschmeckt.“
Deswegen ist es immer, immer, immer sinnvoll,
wenn man da kleine Schildchen dran macht und
die Sorte gleich mit drauf schreibt, so dass
man später im Garten dann auch weiß, welche
Sorten diejenigen sind, die besonders lecker
sind, die besonders ertragreich sind, und
welche Sorten man nächstes Jahr vielleicht
nicht unbedingt noch einmal anbauen muss.
Was aber noch viel wichtiger ist als die Temperatur,
ist das Licht.
Das ist wirklich das allerallerallerwichtigste,
wenn man Tomatenpflanzen selber vorziehen
möchte.
Die brauchen super viel Licht, und zwar 16
Stunden am Tag, und das schafft eine normale
Fensterbank einfach nicht, und das ist wahrscheinlich
auch der Grund, warum, wenn du schon einmal
schwächliche Tomatenpflanzen hattest, warum
die so langgezogen sind und so schwächlich
und so leicht umknicken.
Das liegt ganz oft daran, dass sie zu wenig
Licht haben.
Deswegen verwende ich LED-Pflanzenlichter,
das sind so LED-Panele, die leuchten in allen
möglichen grellen Farben, die Pflanzen eben
brauchen.
Licht besteht ja aus unterschiedlichen Farben,
und die Pflanzen brauchen unterschiedliche
Farben, um zum Beispiel ihre Blätter gut
zu entwickeln oder ihre Wurzeln, und diese
LED-Panele, die sind so ausgelegt, dass es
optimal ist, um Jungpflanzen vorzuziehen.
Und die LED-Panele, die habe ich einfach mit
einer Zeitschaltuhr so eingestellt, dass sie
von sechs bis 22 Uhr leuchten, also 16 Stunden
am Tag.
Und das ist wirklich der allerwichtigste Faktor,
warum Gemüsepflanzen – es geht nicht nur
um Tomaten, sondern um alle Gemüsepflanzen,
die man Zuhause vorziehen möchte – nicht
gelingen: Dass man versucht, das an der Fensterbank
irgendwie hinzukriegen, weil die meisten Fenster
haben einfach nicht genug Licht, als dass
man den Pflanzen da irgendwie gerecht werden
könnte.
Ich kann euch gerne die LED-Panele hier unter
dem Video verlinken, die ich da verwende.
Habt ihr auch schon Gemüse vorgezogen?
Seid ihr auch schon so fleißig am Aussäen
und Pikieren?
Ja?
Dann erzählt mir das gerne einmal unten in
den Kommentaren, ich finde das immer ganz
nett, da mit euch zu plaudern.
Und übrigens, falls ihr das nicht wusstet:
Ich bin immer, wenn ein Video online geht,
also samstags um zehn, für eine Stunde online
und beantworte alle Kommentare, also soweit
ich komme.
Also wenn ihr konkrete Fragen habt oder so,
dann kommt gerne samstags um zehn unter das
neue Video, und da kann ich euch dann ganz
schnell weiterhelfen, da bin ich immer bis
elf Uhr online.
Wenn die Tomatenpflänzchen aufgegangen sind,
dann haben die ja erst einmal zwei Blätter,
die ein bisschen anders aussehen als die echten
Tomatenblätter.
Das sind die Keimblätter.
Und danach, nach diesem ersten Blattpaar,
entwickeln sich die richtigen ersten Blätter.
Und sobald deine Tomatenpflänzchen so groß
sind, gilt es, dass sie von ihrem großen
Töpfchen in eigene Töpfe umziehen.
Die brauchen dann nämlich mehr Platz, und
dann geht es an das sogenannte Pikieren.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass man das mit Tomaten
macht, weil die das sehr gerne haben.
Die können ja auch nicht/ in so einem überfüllten
Töpfchen können die überhaupt nicht groß
werden.
Also die brauchen wirklich einen großen Topf,
der sollte einen Durchmesser von elf bis 13
Zentimetern haben, größer ist natürlich
immer besser, und den fülle ich auch wieder
mit gut gereiftem und gesiebtem Kompost.
Und da pikiere ich die Pflanzen so rein, dass
nur noch die Blätter zu sehen sind.
Also der ganze Stängel sollte eingepflanzt
werden und mit Erde bedeckt werden bis zu
den untersten Blättern.
Das ist gut, weil sich dann noch mehr Wurzeln
bilden und weil die Pflänzchen dann stabiler
stehen.
Und noch ein Tipp: Wenn du deine Pflanzen
pikierst, dann halte die immer an den Blättern
fest, die mögen das nämlich überhaupt nicht,
wenn man sie am Stängel quetscht.
Also immer, egal, ob es Tomaten sind oder
andere Gemüse, immer an den Blättern halten,
wenn du die umtopfst.
Und wenn wir schon einmal dabei sind, ist
hier noch ein Tipp: Wenn sich bei einzelnen
Tomatenpflänzchen die Keimblätter nicht
richtig ausbreiten, also die allerersten Blätter,
wenn die irgendwie verkrumpelt sind oder immer
noch so ein bisschen eingeklappt, dann reiß
diese Pflänzchen raus.
Ich weiß, es tut weh, Kleien Pflänzchen
rauszureißen, ich mache das auch nicht gerne,
aber das sind die Pflanzen, die später einen
sehr schlechten Ertrag abwerfen würden und
immer hinter den anderen hinterherhinken würden.
Deswegen kann man da schon so ein bisschen
selektieren und die Pflanzen von vornherein
rausreißen, weil da lohnt es sich nicht,
die ganze Arbeit reinzustecken, die man beim
Vorziehen, beim Pflanzen, beim Anbauen von
Tomaten ja aufbringen muss.
Wenn deine Pflänzchen dann zwei, drei Wochen
alt sind, dann wird es Zeit für die erste
Düngergabe.
Ich mache das immer über das Gießwasser.
Da nehme ich biologischen Flüssigdünger,
also mit einem Bio-Siegel drauf.
Das ist immer ganz wichtig, dass man da wirklich
darauf achtet, dass immer ein Bio-Siegel drauf
ist, weil ganz viele Dünger machen irgendwie
auf Bio, aber die sind überhaupt nicht Bio,
das ist die reinste Chemie-Pampe.
Deswegen achte ich da immer drauf, ist ja
hinten auf der Flasche meistens drauf, dass
da wirklich ein Bio-Siegel drauf ist.
Für die Jungpflanzenanzucht verdünne ich
den Flüssigdünger aber noch sehr stark,
also doppelt so stark wie auf der Packung
angegeben ist.
So viel Dünger brauchen die Pflanzen nämlich
am Anfang gar nicht.
Es ist wichtig, dass sie so einen kleinen
Stickstoffschub bekommen in dem Alter, also
im Alter von zwei bis drei Wochen.
Auch im Kompost ist sehr viel weniger Stickstoff
enthalten, als die meisten Leute denken.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass man diese Düngergabe
gibt, aber eben sehr, sehr stark verdünnt
am Anfang noch.
Den Bio-Dünger gibst du also in dein Gießwasser,
und dann gießt du deine Tomaten damit ganz
normal.
Es ist immer am schlauesten, die so zu gießen,
dass das Wasser in der Unterlage steht.
Also nicht oben in den Topf rein gießen,
sondern in die Unterlage, in der deine ganzen
Töpfchen stehen, so dass das Wasser sich
hoch in den Topf saugen kann.
Das ist die beste Art, Jungpflanzen zu gießen,
und so kannst du die auch über das Gießwasser
düngen.
Wenn es soweit ist, dann zeige ich euch natürlich,
wie man die Tomaten im Garten pflanzt oder
im Gewächshaus, ich habe noch ganz viele
andere Tomatenvideos geplant für dieses Jahr,
also abonniert gerne den Kanal und drückt
auf die Glocke, damit ihr informiert werdet,
sobald das nächste Video erscheint.
Vergesst nicht, euch fürs Boot Camp anzumelden,
der Link ist wie gesagt unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Da drüben zeige ich euch meine fünf allerliebsten
Tomatensorten.
Wenn ihr da noch Inspiration braucht, schaut
gerne einmal vorbei.
Da unten ist auch noch ein spannendes Video.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja gleich da oder
da wieder.
Bis dann, tschüss!